this podcast and every other podcast
that I make is brought to you by our
supporters on patreon they get episodes
early unedited and AD free if you'd like
to support check the link in the
description I wanted to talk about Game
of the Year stuff knowing that like
we're always really bad at this I did
ask Troy for his input and he listed the
bear and boulders Gate 3 uh which I felt
were very good picks the Bear in
Boulders Gate 3 or he was referring to
them separately but why not both I like
that have you guys seen the bear
no but Troy has also recommended it to
me I will get to it I promise eventually
it is very good I just for me it's one
of those ones of like after a long
stressful day of running a kitchen slash
game company it really worries me like
going and I don't know I just want to
watch like Darth stuff at the end of the
day it's very
um warming though you like you watch you
know these people in their kitchen these
little artists and level designers in
their kitchen uh really
Blossom um and it's really you have one
guy who works for me one guy who works
for me used to work in the kitchen and
he does occasionally say yes chef to me
and it makes me happier than anything
else that happens to me that's I love it
I love it um also usually when I've say
something stupid go on
my uh audio is not working properly so
you guys uh sorry if there's a slight
Echo um I just like keep having audio
problems it's that's my game of the year
when my audio Works AIO problems yeah um
but yeah whatever what are either of you
picked I do feel like before we even go
into games we liked this year which
there are a bunch that I want to give a
shout out to uh we have to address the
egregious amount of layoffs this year
feel like it's really difficult to talk
about wow it's been such a good year for
gaming when it's also been
simultaneously like one of the worst
years for the industry in recorded
history um obviously we want to
celebrate the games that even the people
who get laid off made and made very well
but damn uh yeah 10,000 or so I think we
at in terms of playoffs this year um he
keeps going up right there was a few
more at Cody's um code Mar sorry talking
to an international audience code
Masters cies that's what you call it
cod's is yeah Cod Master called cod's by
British people which is something I've
never said in front of American and I'm
realizing I would have not known what
you were talking about nope yeah that's
fun that's a fun little cultural
exchange Cody's uh up in up in LM um
yeah no it sucks and as well
like I find it interesting that I think
those two things might be related the
fact that we have had some you know a
lot of big games with big
investment and also a lot of layoffs
those two things it's worth drawing that
link for the audience I think as well
because it's something that doesn't get
talked about much how how do you
elaborate okay um so during Co um lots
of people stayed home which meant the
games made a lot more money which means
that uh a lot of Investments were made
into future games because the one thing
about capitalism is the number always
goes up right so these people who are
staying home they're always going to be
home playing and buying games so this
new Marketplace this is what we're
dealing with true cannot go down number
only go up the number can't go down the
number only goes up so once the number
did go down when everyone or a lot of
people went back to their day-to-day
lives and kind of stopped spending as
much money on home entertainment um that
did leave this kind of big gulf and a
lot of companies basically overextended
themselves and and put themselves in a
position where they couldn't kind of
keep going at the scale that they'd
grown to um and it can happen to any
company obviously under different
circumstances but I do think the fact
that a lot of ambitious and expensive
games have come out and the fact that a
lot of people then couldn't sustain the
jobs that they' created you know they
had to kind of lay those people off
those two things are related it's it's
not a positive or A negative it's
obviously a negative the people being
laid off but I do think that those two
things there is an economic link between
the two interesting I had assumed it was
more
preemptive um in that I don't know the
economic people are uh oh that doesn't
help forecasting economics bad and that
it numbers go down forecasting numbers
go down um that's true as well that's
that's also a factor for sure yeah I
mean for sure a factor as well Co was
huge for video games in such a bizarre
way you know like the ways in which Co
was a massive success for certain
industries is very
unsettling obviously farmer but when
isn't farmer popping off number do only
go up until somebody goes to jail people
be coughing um yeah no it's it's a it is
a uh yeah no there's definitely that
link and I I think um I think the
mistake that was made was a lot of a lot
of business people didn't really think
about the fact that that bubble might
not last forever and then when it didn't
a lot of people had to make adjustments
but yeah we have we suitably put a cloud
over this I think we have haven't we but
we have to do it has to be done
initially I think and also I'd like like
to ask followup question to either of
you
um how
do we feel
about the current notion that it takes a
minimum of five years it's now people
are projecting 5 to 10 to make a AAA
game that model seems unsustainable to
me but I feel like it is being
sustained um well do the layoffs
demonstrate the opposite Define
sustainable I suppose that's the the
thing is if if you're thinking on a
human level then no that is how I'm
think you're thinking is like even that
what does that mean in some people's
careers they'll only have a like you can
quantify the amount of games that you'll
ship at this point uh because you you're
only on Al for so long um and I think
any and if your game doesn't get
canceled of course which can happen part
of it that gets me with that is like
five to 10 years to retain staff is part
of what makes that so like video game
budget so exponentially more expensive
you cannot retain people for 5 years
like the average video game industry job
is 3 years um but 5 to 10 is even if
people have to move you know like
there's so many reasons you can't keep
talent for that long and for every
person you lose and you have to rehire
and backfill it's extremely costly
because you can't even use them for
months because they have to be caught up
like it's just 5 to 10 years is such an
expense in terms of the amount of people
you will lose in that period of time
uh and it again especially when things
can and do get cancelled or Tech
outdates you or like the thing that I
keep thinking of is if you're working on
something for 5 to 10 years what if
something that comes out that's exactly
like what you are working on and you're
like oh [__] like I feel like when the
time's longer that is so much more
likely to happen that someone else makes
the all of your creative efforts
redundant especially considering the
output the games industry actually has
at this point what do we how many games
we got on Steam at this point it's like
a we're in the Thousand they froggy
right or they or something comes out
that absolutely redefines the genre and
you're two years out from I think a lot
of Studios have found themselves in that
position with the with the L not the
looter shooter the I always forget the
name of the new one the the the the one
that the hyenas
was what's the genre of
hyenas of
what was it hyenas the game that got
cancelled that was in development for a
while I don't know I miss so much news
now I mean a battle royale is the pig no
there's a someone it's being posted in
the comments like 20 times as we speak
there's a specific genre of shooter
that's been that that was that basically
is
H say again no hero shoter the one that
came after that this is embarrassing the
genre of shoo okay H is a plan science
fiction firstperson shooter developed by
creative assembly in public I had even
heard of this I don't think okay so that
one that one was a big there was you
know there was a lot of people working
profitability it was a
pvpve right okay is that what you mean
pvpve there's a specific term I'm
thinking it's going to be all over the
comments we'll find we'll learn it when
this comes out it's fine but the but but
my point is that's a there's there there
are genres that can kind of bubble up
and disappear in the time in this window
as you say true you can have you can be
convinced that like you know specific
genre is about to pop off look for a
broader example is games as a service
right most of the games of a service
games as a service that are coming out
or coming out soon or around now um I'm
thinking of like um Justice League kill
the Justice Suicide Squad kill the
Justice League like they when they
started that project they wouldn't have
known the enormous kind of public
opinion shifting that has happened
around that genre and yeah it's a it's a
a great example 5e Dev cycle they've
probably been on that for five years at
this point how are you more
yeah and that's and that's and that's a
challenge and then that cost money
because you have to shift genre you have
to change what your game is and and the
audience then plays the game and goes
well this seems like it was meant to be
something else and and often they're
right right that's that's it's a it's a
massive it's a massive issue and it's
one that it's tough to see a path out of
because the production value that's
expected of that genre of AAA games in
general is just absurd and you do it
does require an enormous amount of work
to get that stuff
done I Austin do you have any opinion on
fiveyear cycle I imagine that makes your
job harder as well right like how do you
um actually I would argue the opposite
I'm the minimum I should say the average
that I'm involved in games is three
years but there have been a few that
pushed into the four five three years on
average W I'm typically involved for the
entirety of it and that's about been the
average of of because there's even on
bigger
games um that have themselves longer
than three-year period uh there's still
often like I remember on syndicate for
example they had spent the first like
year and a half just building London and
so there was nothing really for me to do
there wasn't the script wasn't finished
the actors hadn't been recorded or MOA
yet or anything it was purely Tech
investment for the first uh uh like in
design investment upfront cost
pre-production could be up to a couple
of years as well in a lot of cases you
know and they're not going to call you
for that yeah yeah and so I've I I I
love to be involved super early but
sometimes there are the I'm kind of
involved and mostly just kind of like
looking over the fence on slack and
saying hi and I'm not really actively
doing much yet uh but three years is
tends to be about the average for
productive involvement so because I'm a
freelancer
um I it's like very few games until you
reach the end of the process have like
40 hours a week worth of need of me so
it's pretty easy to have multiple
projects going once because they all
have in Milestones that are kind of
naturally just different so I can focus
on game a for the next six weeks and
check in and make smaller amounts of
progress on game B and game c and then
right as we deliver a big milestone that
one will cool off for a little while and
B is now the focus for what and that
tends to be how it goes now it that can
get tricky because every now and again
things will then pile on top of each
other and they're not even aware of one
another and I can't even really make
them aware of each other without
breaking my NDA with each of them so I
have to just muscle through it it's one
of those
interesting like on the subject of
crunch I know I'm a tangent off of your
actual question but the the I did a talk
a few years ago at GDC with some some
colleagues about this like freelancer
crunch thing that happens in that exact
situation where you are being forced to
double time it through projects that are
overlapping that can't even know about
each other and there's nothing you can
do about that do about it yeah yeah the
only the only way that you could ever
possibly prevent that is by just doing
less work than you can handle which most
people can't afford to do most people
don't wouldn't voluntarily just work
less than needed especially because as
Mike mentioned a second ago some
sometimes you know I've worked on games
for years that then got cancelled you
know and that sort of thing and and you
know and if I was just sort of like
putting all my eggs in that basket as a
freelancer um where there is no
severance pay or any of that kind of
stuff generally speaking uh you know
you'd be you better have a lot lot of
Nest Egg basically to weather that storm
uh and it's it's but it's also just even
if you do have a large Nest Egg it's
just sort of foolish it's a
self-inflicted wound essentially so all
that said
um I I see it as this is driven by the
market fundamentally in players taste
and if and like it does seem
that um players are increasingly not
demanding bigger bigger bigger bigger of
everything the market if nothing else
has Diversified where there is room for
other games and so yeah okay Rockstar is
going to be able to spend like a billion
dollars on a game that they release
every 10 years and that people will be
there for it but like the EAS the
Ubisoft the Sony's can potentially start
to kind of make games that are smaller
and and and I mean look at the success
of Call of Duty uh those single player
campaigns have effectively ignored the
trend for bigger bigger bigger bigger
bigger it's like they've they've held to
this like five hours for the single
player because obviously the multiplayer
is sort of what's probably floating
financially those games and they and
they know that so they've kind of
managed to dodge a lot of the the arms
race I feel like in a in a in a Savvy
way because and for me personally and I
know I'm not alone in this way it's so
satisfying in its conciseness
dramatically prefer it all right yeah I
love it whenever I boot up a game and it
I could talk about forever 10 hours I'm
like oh thank
God but I I get really annoyed if a game
dares to be longer but I do think I
think it's it goes even further than
what's Austin's saying that's a trend
that's really happened in the last few
years is it used to be the argument was
if you're a big company with lots of
money to
invest making a big bet is going to have
a big reward so therefore is a better
use of your money than lots of small
bets and that was something that I
definitely I had to kind of enter the
industry and start like pitching Indie
Games to kind of get that that was the
thinking that oh just give us give us a
a couple of million it's going to be
it's going to be worth your time and you
know you make a bunch of bets it's like
no I'd better off putting all my money
into a 20 million game and potentially
doing bad that is no longer true like if
you look at the games that have really
hit and had like gargantuan success in
the last two or three years it's small
games it's it's consistently small games
it's consistently or like you know
double a kind of scale yeah like I guess
I wouldn't know
like percentage based profits I think
the highest selling game this year or
one of them was Hogwarts Legacy which
would have been massively expensive I
would imagine um but that probably made
nothing compared to the most successful
mobile game I think genion impact has
probably been tremendously successful
that I mean does that count as double A
I don't I don't know probably
not um it does feel like it's shifting
because it used to be that the only
games that made money were the games
that a big budget people only have so
much time right like that's that's the
thing and I know that that's the part of
why so many of the business folks have
shifted towards live service games and
I've been trying to do that so much for
the last 10 years is that like if people
will only buy a certain amount of games
and only play a certain amount of games
what you're actually trying to buy as
people's time you if you make it like
then you have a top down then you have a
top heavy ecosystem your carnivals have
gone too big that's the problem is if
you're if you're in a situation where
everyone's trying to own your for
they're not trying to make a game that
SS you for 10 hours they're trying to
own the free time of a person which
everything is right every app trying to
that to you know yeah that's every time
uh the Apex prodes have gone too big in
an environment and the environment's
collapsed because you can only eat so
much you know so it's it's a yeah that's
certainly the intent there though is
like live service games and then
monetize the hours you
play through obviously different
monetization strategies um that I always
bring this up but there was an
Activision guess AC blizzard uh investor
presentation where they were talking
about wishing that video games could
monetize the same hourly rate that films
do they're like okay well if it's $16 an
hour and someone plays Call of Duty for
100 hours why aren't we getting the same
return as uh a cinema does um even
though obviously the product is entirely
different I don't know that that will
work out well for them but it gives you
an idea of how the business people think
in terms of monetizing player hours not
just selling a game and letting you play
it for 10 hours which again I miss all
the time but every time I started Alan
Wake yesterday the remastered version
just to look at it and he was like this
is only going to take me eight hours to
finish is this Heaven oh my God feels
like a luxury good at that point and it
may well be that that's where this ends
up that you're you're going to you're
going to play those kind of games and
they're going to feel like kind of
connoisseur kind of artisan [__] rather
than like the main stream the main
stream might completely depart from even
Call of Duty most recent one of those
had kind of an underwhelming single
player campaign right they're clearly
investing Less in that component real
dud I think unfortunately so so even
even that stalwart maybe is is is is
losing interest in the single player
which would be a shame because I [__]
love the Call of Duty campaigns but
haven't I mean people have been claiming
the death of single player for so long
and then like look at the biggest games
this year I mean balers gate is an
interesting one because that's not
technically single player but single
player is but it's yeah like it is it is
and it's also one of those where I think
it's a single player Al like it's and
it's single player and it's sort of
ethos in terms of when we talk about
multiplayer and you talk about more like
esport kind of games or things that are
closer to that you know single instance
kind of much closer to sports analogies
that's that's what dominates the notion
of multiplayer or like RPG you know MMO
kind of games whereas a highly narrative
driven single player experience even if
experienced in a co-op way you know some
some of the single biggest games this
year uh are still under that b you know
just Jedi Survivor Resident Evil and
balers gate Allen wake yeah like like so
I I don't this is one of those like it's
been it's been claimed to be on its
deathbed and maybe a very like I haven't
obviously run any kind of analysis on
titles shipped and then sort of cross
referenced with their relative success
that sort of thing maybe it is true that
it's on a downward spiral but just a few
keep reliably making the news like I
remember don't I don't think it is I
think I I again same this is conjecture
but um I think that there's too much
player demand for it I think that there
are suits who would love for single
player games to die and for live service
to replace all of them but truth is
that's what game is like that's why nft
is on appealing to Gamers is like I I
think that people who play video games
really a lot of them not all of them
obviously really enjoy a single player
experience uh and there's no means to
replace that with a live service game
and like as much as they might like them
to die they kind of can't because that's
what players like like the market is
repeated that's true but there is an
economic issue here potentially that I I
I think I I to be clear I'm obviously I
love single player C it's all I make I
love single player games I'm not it's
but but in terms of like it is harder to
fund them for sure than it was because
the you don't have guaranteed inome
business people you're well yeah no
business people are not going to are not
as excited by them as they are by live
service or multiplayer it's very telling
that when you think about the big single
player games now a large number of them
make their money in a different way than
just straight up selling to the customer
so things like uh Game Pass where you're
incentivizing a subscription Allen wake
might not be a multiplayer game but it
is built around a subscription based
pricing model right that's a is that in
Game Pass Al W am I about to embarrass
myself I actually don't know
I'm probably embarrassing myself there
but but this it's definitely true like
by epic yeah it's published by ep I'm
totally wrong man ignore me um so not on
Game Pass launch but still published by
epic which is like this is always my
exception I always want a list for this
kind of stuff single player games will
always survive when people are trying to
get you onto their platform which is the
PlayStation model PlayStation Nintendo
model they make very very very good
single player experiences so you'll buy
their Hardware so then they get the %
cut of everything that you buy on the
store or what it is a popular genre it's
beloved by players and there's an
obvious massive audience who want it but
they only pay once so therefore there is
a ceiling on what the money can be
unless you are yeah selling a platform
yeah and I guess when when people are
inventing other means to monetize like
live service games it's very difficult
for people to go well let's do that I
mean everybody wants to be FIFA Ultimate
Team I said it before I'll say it again
it's the most appealing thing in the
world for everybody to be like make that
thing which nobody can replicate we're
all screwed at the arrow goes up of FIFA
Ultimate
Team um but as much as we could talk
about this forever I love this kind of
conversation I did want to give a shout
out to very good single player game this
is uh in my top five games of the year
that I really wanted to to give a shout
out to um just because I haven't seen it
nominated in a bunch of outlets um it's
called dredge it's not unheard of um it
is an indie fishing game made by a l
craan right it's kind of Horror made by
Studio where it's better if I sort of
don't tell you anything um where just
the more that you play this sweet little
Coastal Indie fishing game made by a New
Zealand team things get creepier and
creepier um and you sell
on buy equipment and you catch fish and
uh it it's got a unexpectedly engrossing
story and really sharp gameplay
beautiful art style so I wanted to list
that as my pick of like while I think
bald is Gate 3 will definitely win game
of the year and I absolutely adore Alan
wink too and I have very positive things
to say about RoboCop like there have
been a lot of great games this year
RoboCop surprised a lot of people like
RoboCop is like I'm going to make a
video about it that's going to get no
views um but the game Direction you know
how like I don't think a lot of Gamers
necessarily know what the game Direction
award is and I feel like the RoboCop's
directing is so [__] good um so also
love that just in terms of it's like
consistency and how it comes together
the way that the the tone of that game
from gameplay to dialogue to Performance
the curation of the experience it all
comes together yeah and I I feel like I
haven't seen a game do Direction quite
that well especially when it's got a
sense of humor um since every Yak is a
game like they're so well directed it's
so sidebar licenses are really helpful
for directors they're an amazing North
Star really help guide you and you stud
only made liced games actually they've
only done like 80s it does I'm not
diminishing it but I I definitely being
able to like point to in in my case Tron
and be like that's what we're going for
everyone you know it's definitely a nice
Shand for for sure yeah there's
certainly helpful working on
aliens uh to have a list of dos and
don'ts uh I still can I can I nominate
Austin's head shot noise as my game of
the of the decade the uh in Al in the
aliens game that every single that twang
every single time you get a head shot
just made that game it's beautiful I
still to this day do not remember who
actually came up with that um uh or like
or what you a it was you it was your
vision well that's the thing I'm so
hesitant to take credit for it because
I'm like it I don't I am I a genius uh
am I a Genus some say a modern day Boart
it wasn't
that's what they say the the fact of
having a headshot noise was for sure not
my idea the question was where the
actual sound came from uh but that was
the the notion of there being a headshot
noise I definitely didn't come up with
that I just don't remember because it
sounds so much like some of the uh brass
things that we recorded for the for the
score um but I just can't remember
because it's it's already now perfect
example of of like they I signed on to
that game before Disney bought Fox wow
because I was hired by Fox people and
then shipped a game with Disney people
so weird uh so like to give a sense of
the timeline it was like 2018 or
something like that when I was hired so
it's it feels like ages ago now um but
um dredge I I keep hearing about dredge
and I sore I had bought it and I
apparently hadn't so highly recommend it
yeah that's I wanted to give it as as my
playwatch list and nomination uh game of
the year uh just is one that I highly
recommend um which related to either of
you to you can give me a game movie book
Tv show uh nominator thing of the year
the official playwatch listen Awards
I'll send him an
email you've you've been
nominated um I mean I'm trying to think
in terms of uh broader medium I quite
uh this is hardly a deep cut but I was I
was really impressed with Oppenheimer as
a film I saw it when they brought it
back into theaters for a week for the 70
millimeter IMAX showings and um I was
just so blown away that on a on that
scale of film making we didn't have a
conversation about it did we I don't
think we recorded after that I I also
loved
Oppenheimer um and I want to watch it
again because I think I'm ready to
finally um you need to read the script
I that it's written it's written in
first person which is just such an
interesting formal weirdness I've read
the whole Dark Knight script and it's a
it's a really good read I have that as a
book downstairs um it that that movie's
just edited so fast that I think the
first time that I watched it I had
whiplash for the first maybe 20 minutes
cuz like oh my God it's a new scene
again uh it's just so quick until it's
not um in a way that I I think works so
well for the discomfort of the era that
like you're just con everything is
constantly moving you because it's
edited so fast become a part of the race
like it's just yeah it's a
really feels like memory as well feels
like how your brain jumps around totally
very impressive movie
I the ambition and the you know the
hundred million price tag to make a
movie that on paper like this is in a
way appropo the kind of single player
versus games of service that's a game
that the pitch likely did not other than
the Christopher Nolan of it and he just
being his own draw that's the only
reason I got green lit that's my that
was my main when I read the screenplay
is like how like nobody with any other
name could have gotten anyone to read
this past the 10th page because you're
reading it and like unless you've seen
the movie it's gibberish like it doesn't
like the structure of it it's amazing
and Al just the the pitch of we want to
make a film about
Oppenheimer that kind of is one foot in
the kind of arms race
sciency component of what the Manhattan
Project was and is another component in
this kind of
psychological uh anguish of of being
involved in the man lot communism in
that and lot of talk
communism finally Nolan's going to make
a movie about like a Nerge that no one
understands he doesn't get to see his
family enough that's the that's the
dream that's the finally that's POS
that's all that said I'm pretty certain
that when I finally see Maestro it will
decimate everything uh uh for me U of
this year in terms of of the Year's
games I'm not familiar what's
myo are you are you being are you
[__] with me uh I can't tell
sometimes times Coy Mike is
indifferentiable from Ernest Mike no I
genu sorry I apologies I have no idea
what Maestro is talk mro is the film
about Leonard Bernstein with Bradley
Cooper that's uh just come out on
Netflix oh I saw I remember seeing a I I
remember people talking about the makeup
because he's got a fake nose hasn't he
he looks he looks exactly like Bernstein
yeah people people made a hang up hang
up of it and then go to a museum me and
you about Bernstein at some point yeah
and we went to the skirball to see their
Henson exhibit and they by dumb luck had
a Bernstein Exhibit while we were there
and I freaked out yeah I mean like I've
got a painting of him right here that
anilla made and my friend Andrea gave me
this photo Lego Amazing he had such a
good time Lely I uh it everyone who has
uh seen it that I've talked to so far
has been over the moon about it uh my
last month or just no last week yeah
that is last
month well okay yeah true fair uh but
that's is it one that you're saving you
saving it for like I need to no I've
just been busy we're like moving house
and stuff and there's been [__] and I
was traveling and so it's like I I I'm
terrified that it's going to leave the
theater before I have the chance to see
it because uh I've been it's been a
hetic I didn't even know it was in
theaters I thought it was just on
Netflix it's on both they did an
Irishman any film that Netflix has Oscar
Ambitions for they will I was say it's
for the awards right they have to they'
put in that for a little while yeah but
everyone I've s Everyone is saying like
Bradley Cooper should be a complete shoe
in for director uh on this H and um U
Carrie Mulligan as well for playing
Felicia Mont monra uh uh so Austin's
nomination for thing of the year is a
movie he hasn't seen I'm just sure but I
will say I know I know that I'm I'm
slotting right into a very mainstream
opinion but if nothing else by kind of
evaluation of putting my time SL money
where my mouth is No Game can come close
to the number of hours for me as balder
gate as balers Gate 3 I've played I've
played that game like north of 110 120
hours and it's like the second place
Contender for that for me this year is
like 30 you know like to beat Jedi
Survivor so balers Gate 3 I was
streaming it at first and then stopped
because I was so [__] bad at it um
and streaming it like if you're bad at
something makes it worse I had the same
problem with alen wake too where it's
like I shouldn't be streaming this I it
doesn't I don't pay attention to the
right things um I had thought a a
mechanic was far more complicated than
it actually was um balers Gate 3 is like
one of those games that even though
we're talking about loving 10hour
experiences I never want to stop playing
it's very difficult to put down because
you're
always intertwined in like three very
compelling subplots at once and the
minute one is about to be let go another
one shows up it's like Mike I'm sure you
actually have this to I was going to say
it's like it's like when you're writing
and you're like very much on a roll but
you have to go to bed and you're like oh
I really don't want to finish doing this
I really don't want to put this down I
get that exan exact same excited [__]
yeah this is awesome feeling from baldis
Gate 3 every time I touch it it's you're
getting a flow State playing B dis Sky
that's amazing yeah it it uh and to the
kind of in a sense to wrap it back to
the whole question of sustainability of
big teams and that and where the
conversation started um it's it's only
very very peripherally related to that
but just the idea that that one of the
things that makes
unsustainable massive games is the fact
that that attrition rate of people
coming and going where if someone if you
have this ship of thesis problem where
the people that are shipping the game
are so massively different from those
who started it um that's just going to
take a toll and and and and something I
found very Charming I had I was in Gent
in Belgium uh for an event of a month
and a half ago or whatever which is
happens to be where laran is based and
and uh a bunch of laran folks came to
this event that I was I was at at this
kind of Afterparty thing and I was
talking to a few of them and I don't
think you'll find people more excited
about balers Gate 3 on the planet than
larryan like employee they I I said to
them I was like okay so I'm I'm in the
third act and I walk into this what I
thought was an abandoned store because I
just figured there might be some basic
loot I can sell or whatever and
and um it's like a coffin manufact it's
like a coffin
maker and I said I have a perception
check reveal that there's a movable
bookcase and I thought oh there's
probably a hidden room and I'm about to
stop playing because it's late and blah
blah blah and I could see them they were
frothing at the mouth knowing where this
story is going because of course you
move the thing you go back and there's
like 10 hours more content on the other
side of this completely
innocuous bookcase that you could easily
have skipped um and but it's it's not
just fluffy random crap there's like
consequential interesting stuff back
there and they of course they they knew
exactly what I was talking about and
they were so excited and they were like
oh how cool who was in your party and
they were just so wired by it and it was
like I I find that people that don't
feel like they're just kind
of uh serving their time at the company
but they're so bought in in what they're
making and these were not like the art
director and the so this was like a
junior you know animation person or like
a a like these in other words these were
these were folks that in the grand
scheme of the company were not major
decision makers but they felt so
invested they they clearly were making
an impact and they felt they felt like
they were part of it and because they
obviously were they obviously Were You
know despite a lack of seniority deeply
impactful to the success of of the game
I wonder if it's also one of those ones
where the game's so big that even in
development you wouldn't have
necessarily seen everything that oh I'm
sure players seeing and that that's got
to be so cool right like I don't think
there was any part of Ragnarok that I
wasn't aware of but like a game like
Boulders Gate 3 is
so I'm sure the team was playing
obviously was on Early Access so it's it
it's had a thousand play hours before it
even came out like thousands and
thousands I can
I can uh I can say I've borne witness to
this very recently um uh I I I'm only
sort of just now able to talk about this
but the new Lego fortnite that just got
announced I scored um oh cool and um um
you and Eminem right yeah we buddied up
no actually I I did work with another
composer they brought in two of us to to
hack through it uh Chuck Myers who was
one of the Hogwarts Legacy composers was
also um part of the team and and um that
game when they when they broadened it
when the internal play testing at Epic
uh sort of broadened and and they were
you know getting a sense of how the
systems are working and you know the
game one of the appropo Legos one of the
things it Prides itself on is a pretty
robust kind of procedural physics
potential where you can really just kind
of build whatever um and and and systems
are capable of being created that that
no one can predict and so there were
these moments where people would try
things that the core design team had
never thought of like just other people
inter internal epic would do a thing and
give them that first taste of oh my
God I I didn't ever I never even thought
to to do that and just like the giddy
childlike joy that that was spreading
throughout the team internally of people
going oh man you can do this and I oh
wow I never thought if you combine this
and that and and um so yeah to see
people work on a thing unaware of even
its full potential uh that to me that's
one of the coolest things about games
that makes it totally different as a
medium from film and TV because it's
rare unless your job is like oh I come
in and I I'm part of the construction
crew on a set like those people likely
haven't read the full script and don't
really care that their job is very
specific and they're going to come in
and do it and by the time they're
shooting that scene they're probably
building another set on an unrelated
production sort of thing yeah like
imagine what is of the Kingdom
right and being like whoa I didn't know
you could do that like watching plays
make something that you couldn't even
comprehend and like BS Gate 3 obviously
you're not doing that but I feel like
there are so many permutations you know
they just had an update where they added
another like thousand
lines can't even imagine how many are
already in there at this point I mean
it's just it's like it's like a million
lines of dialogue I mean it's absolutely
Bonkers so yeah that's one of those
that's one of those funny things that
actually being a composer
I have an atypical bird's eye view
because the work will span the the whole
game so the the most common is you know
like our disadvantage is we trade width
for depth sometimes the full extent of
what's possible in a game is hard to
fully comprehend but there won't be big
chunks of it that I'm unaware of now of
course the goal is to have maximum
amounts of both and just play test the
crap out of it while you're working on
it and that's where having multiple
years helps but but yeah the um the like
it will be fun to talk to level
designers where they're they're not
really aware of the full extent of
what's going on with other level
designers because they've they've got
plenty to do just focusing on their sort
of portion of actually Syndicate as a
good example once again I remember it
was the Singapore studio um of Ubisoft
that did there's like a Flash Forward in
that game that goes to World War II
where you play um Eevee Fry's daughter
and that was like a whole other Studio
on a different part of the world and so
I remember when the folks in Canada got
like when that you know those assets
like became visible in the in the build
and stuff everyone was like holy [__]
this is amazing like what have they been
doing down there like it was it was cool
I feel like that's like my whole job
though like is I I do something and then
somebody else makes it cooler I think I
do that every week and have for the last
three years I go holy [__] that like
somebody made something and I could see
it
uh that's probably a pretty big part of
Game Dev uh but I guess in that instance
what they received was done like it was
actually finished whereas most of the
time it's incremental right it's
definitely a very cool part of the job
though it's like just being blown away
by people making cool big jump forwards
as well those sudden moments where just
a bunch of stuff gets dropped in yeah
yeah it's amazing a amazing incredible
how do they do it it's the best um so I
think Austin nominated Oppenheimer there
as how well I said preemptively Maestro
thing you haven't seen for sure
Oppenheimer blew me away uh yeah I'm
very excited to see new gibl movie I'm
going to nominate that too thing I
haven't seen oh yeah that looks great
seeing you next week um Mike what is
your uh thing you liked this year play
watch listen Awards
I've honestly I've not played enough
games again I knew this would be the
problem when I texted Troy and was like
if you happen to be free he did say he
was traveling for this episode I was
like no pressure they're not going to
have played anything it's
fine I've played like four games this
year tops like I I uh I like Spider-Man
too I thought that was very good I've
always been incredibly impressed by that
studio um so I I'd go for like a movie
or TV show I think
um watch a lot of T season three of
never have
ever I've never seen I've never seen
never have I ever give me the synopsis
in two sentences what's never have I
ever it's teenage girl coming of age
story but very specifically through uh
indian-american perspective a friend of
mine was like you got to watch this and
I was like I don't think I'm the
audience for this uh and then I am super
Unapologetic about the fact that that
show is addicting and really Charming uh
and was like you know what [__] it I
don't I don't give a [__] it's really
like all power to
him and Janina goanar our Freddy and
stray Gods had a random bit part in an
episode and I was like yes she's one of
those people that every time she shows
up I do the meme yeah like she's an
Allen White too and I was
like where' she come from um I liked I
tell you what I I really liked that I
don't think enough people watch was
Pokerface I don't think that one crossed
over much I don't even know what that is
no I think in America it's on peacock
which is probably why no one's seen it
um it's um Ryan Johnson directing
writing and directing a Columbo style
detective show but the gimmick is um
well the gimmick of the character is
that the main character um has a
perfectly tuned [__] detector so she
can't be lied to so every every case h
hinges on working out a way to make that
interesting and then structurally it's
very cool that you it's the Columbo
thing if you see the crime committed and
then she shows up so it's not who done
it it's how's she going to catch them um
that's genuinely good and it's also got
like a serialized narrative it's just a
really good um yeah very like perfect
combination of like episodic detective
show and serialized TV and great cast
and just phenomenally good and then
movie wise the Creator I really admired
like just from a production point of
view like I don't know if you two have
seen that the
the Gareth Edwards no it actually didn't
appeal to me the Creator uh I thought
like I didn't watch it because I thought
it looked quite
generic it's definitely like the visual
style of it is 100% every 3D artist
portfolio I've looked at in the last two
years 100% like it's definitely it's got
that look to it but no it's I've been a
fan of his um since like Monsters like
the stuff he's done in terms of um kind
of gorilla sci-fi fil film making is
really like I don't know if you saw
monsters but that was literally he shot
so he basically it's it's a it's a movie
about the quarantine Zone around a Kaiju
have happened and there's a quarantine
Zone around the area that they've
emerged and a guy's sent in to save um a
woman it's a love story about the two of
them on a road trip G to know each other
while the world is ending around them
love that but it was shot incredibly
cheaply by filming um on the American
Mexican borders all of the like order
control stuff that was already in place
for that they kind of CG in kind of
monster signage and story lot of using
um uh real people as actors doing doing
kind of St like documentary it kind of
starts to get towards kind of Nathan
Fielder stuff even like but like it's
it's it's fascinating and the Creator
similar the Creator is just an
incredibly tightly produced movie very
small budget comparatively um and just
really excellent use of CG like visual
effects work like there's a lot of bad
VFX now because of the way VFX companies
are treated often and things can go
wrong and people don't have the time
they need to do things Etc but that's a
that's a very clearly a film directed by
a VFX guy because every shot is chosen
very carefully everything is playing to
the strength of what he knows he can get
done um and as someone who similarly
Works in that kind of end of the budget
spect
that's crazy it was literally as far as
I know it was and I'm sure this is
always these things are always
exaggerated it was literally like him in
a car with a with a digital video camera
two actors what people can make with
limitations is is always so much more
interesting than what you can make with
you should what it's it's it's probably
i' would say monsters is morees have
great review probably yeah it's probably
true of the Creator as well they're not
as good movies as they are just
incredibly impressive exercises in how
oh yeah I'm down for that yeah
I would watch monsters it's it's it's
it's not excellent I've not watched it
in years so my age
terribly but like it's um yeah I I I'm I
I like my process I like my um like
seeing people working with limitations
like that it's really cool um and then
um the curse if no one's watched that
which is just breaking my brain every
week at the moment have you seen that I
don't I don't know if I like it or not
it's it's it's Nathan Fielder and um oh
my God I'm a nerd so Stacy yeah
emerstone I've I've seen it
advertised yeah it's really anxiety
inducing his I think it's a comedy but
it's yeah but it's like more so than
like his other stuff um I think I like
it I think I like it but I do always get
in a bad mood watching it so I don't
know it's interesting
lovely um I have to run
I got a do we we didn't mention uh an
obvious one but uh because it's been a
while now but the [__] audacity of
the sequel to the
spiderverse uh was unbelievable like
that film that film I hope is not
forgotten when the Oscars uh roll out
because God I just watched it a second
time recently and I was like I also love
the Ninja Turtles movie this year that
was surprisingly great way better than I
expected I expected just to just be a
spider us clone and it's not it's really
good yeah I I that was one of those
plain watches for me because I was like
I'm sure this is not going to be good
and I was 100% into it I was like this
is this is great yeah super fun yeah but
spite of us is like on a level of its
own both of them are I actually still
prefer the original which I think is an
unpopular opinion um but I think I think
they're both so good that you it's that
level of Excellence where you kind of
forget how clever what you're seeing is
like how like it's it transcends visibly
impressive they're virtually perfect
insane the sequel the way that the
sequel so Unapologetic would change
everything about its aesthetic from one
shot to the next in the middle of a
scene just for the sake of the three
words that were going to be spoken in
the new shot and trying to capture them
subjectively I was like this is a level
of non-realistic film
making it's it's an extreme that any
other context people would have said oh
it's this like super Niche little art
film and the fact that they managed to
squeeze it into a Spider-Man effectively
the biggest movie IP ever like
Spider-Man almost second and on I really
upset some film Bros by saying that I
think I would put those two movies in my
top 50 best movies of all time they like
but the Godfather like people really
really didn't like that but I stand by I
was going to say wh which movie about
like a conflicted angry man would you
push out that would upset the film nerds
for a conflicted angry boy uh yeah they
they they definitely piss some people
off there but I I just think like if I
can ever make anything that's as good as
one frame of either of those f
I'm good so incredible amazing so no
okay I have to run thank you everybody
for uh listening to our annual uh really
bad wrapup of things we enjoyed this
year we did our best we tried all right
we'll see you next time
bye